I brought the first time I ever brought
someone this is one of my favorite
stories to tell first time I brought
someone I bring Tom Segura up to
Sacramento now this is when Tom had hair
and he used to comb it back but you've
been doing comedy long in the top he
gets up this is by the way fat Tom no
beard Tom like button-down like relaxed
shirt Tom my ears deep in Connie's thumb
at this point he's Tom this is that Tom
okay this is that Tom he used to comb
his hair back you comb it all the way
back right he's gotten a lot better so
he goes up you do 30 minutes Compton's
maybe yeah yeah
Tom's maybe we're doing stand-up I had
maybe like four years
I'm guessing five years and he goes up
and it's Sacramento it's a bee Club it's
called laughs unlimited is a tough crowd
you had really improv and do a little
crowd work to get him with you and Tom
goes up with straight material and it's
straight like aggressive material and
they are not having it and he is not
getting laughs not not funny it's
[ __ ] not you he's doing four years eh
laughs not one laugh joke stops they
don't realize that stop starts a new
joke they're not confused huh what's
going on and he starts sweating are you
in the back I'm in the back watching
he's sweating and as he says he
continues to sweat his hair starts
flattening to his head right and it's
thinning and at one point there is one
line of hair there's one combed line of
hair like this and everyone is watching
their nose no hearing a joke they're
hearing that one line of hair and his
joke bombs and the hair collapses he
gets off soaking wet he goes that didn't
go good no it's like I know I was like
maybe don't open here like this really
aggressive rape choke a baby don't open
with a rape joke and he was like you
think
he I've seen him bomb so [ __ ] we
waited we did we did we did one time we
did we did Hawaii together right and
they go be clean whatever you can like
this is this is [ __ ] this is dirt 13
years ago Lana just had eyeless at 13 14
maybe 12 years ago 10 years ago so we do
why the person we're supposed to go with
cancel last-minute Tom's good friends
with Russell Peters he goes let's see if
we get Russell he's a big international
act they booked Russell to me Tom
Russell Peters we're having a great time
we're doing fun things we go to we go to
one of the shooting cut things and the
guy and Russell wheel Russell you want
to go needles ah I think I'm gonna go
shopping today okay so Tom and I take
the girls and we go there and the first
thing that guy says is we've got one
rule here on Pearl Harbor if it's brown
and it moves you shoot it and we're at
good thing we didn't invite Russell I
know I bomb I bomb immediately and I'm a
little dirty
you opened I open because it was a rough
show so I go I'll open it Tom I'll give
you an easier spot and then Russell kill
different Tom's like yeah they go
whatever you do don't make fun of Hawaii
and don't bring up Pearl Harbor that war
and we're like okay sure not that's not
in either of our acts I go up and I eat
it and Tom decides to pivot and goes up
and he goes hey man it's beautiful here
in Hawaii they say island life is slow I
didn't know they were talking about
their metabolisms man Hawaiians are fat
you know I was walking around the base
today and I got lost luckily I ran into
a bunch of Japanese guys they really
know their way around this base huh and
now we can hear the [ __ ] commander
going what the [ __ ] is going on what the
[ __ ] is going on Tom gets off the host
the host of the night the host of the
night then goes put your hands together
for Russell Peters we realize we're
sitting with 12,000 people have been
taught if it's brown and it moves shoot
it I hope he doesn't move around a lot
so hard
miss you know those hurt they hurt so
bad yeah hey the breakfast the next
morning we went to the beach and we were
like I was like how you feeling he's
like not good never do this again
but the [ __ ] to giggle about it now
is like greatest I cannot Kealing I want
a closer reason me Tom and Christina and
Lea and my wife are so close is that we
sat at the beach the next day getting
drunk and I'm just commiserating about
how bad it would Tom met where we met we
met he was I was opening for Jay Mohr
and we were Brea and he was in the how
long jumper is this my this is it's got
it before I had kids so sixteen years
seven sixteen years married 17 years I
walk in toms watching the FSU game Jay
wasn't having a good day Thomas it was
never a good day right so she's watching
the FSU game I went to Eva's you I walk
in and I go hey man
FSU and he goes yeah he found I said I
want to have studios that's my favorite
team I go hey I'm Burton he goes I'm Tom
J walks in and he was tough [ __ ] you
guys watching and Tom goes Dave a shoe
game I got hundred dollars on it and
look somebody goes you're the host you
make $50 a night you 100 all your
[ __ ] idiot walks out at a good time
ago hey what were the tour I don't get
why you and Tom don't tour together it's
good like why not do it two bears one
cave where the [ __ ] it is why don't we
want to do a tour like that like that
would sell like a you guys walk through
the biggest kind of the world that would
sell like [ __ ] hotcakes
I think ultimately honestly I mean not
to like show how the sausage is made
no no not money at all really he's
wrapped by and I'm reprobate and neither
our agents want to do business with each
other [ __ ] yeah I know but it becomes
super complicated because dude I mean
even just like even like like that [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] it's why Justin when justice
started its very wisely just started
look yeah he started gathering
although all the like the death squad
comics and it was such a brilliant move
and I don't think everyone looked at it
that way
that's why I always respond you spec
just a smartass
you just
yeah and he had all these guys he was
like he could easily do a [ __ ] tour
put together you well you guys did the
[ __ ] thing in in Arizona Arizona know
what we're doing in June Chicago theater
and Ryan
Bobby Lee Santino and me we're doing
three big cities yeah that's gonna be so
much fun you know ideas that to me like
what like everyone makes money you know
it's always about money how do I don't
give a [ __ ] about any of that
how come on would it be if you Tom
D'Elia Rogen brine me I'll host that
[ __ ] I don't there's no ego for
me I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm the new comer I'll host it I don't
care if I'm a Lenny I would hate you or
you'll do 20 minutes and you'll fun
maybe you can go back to that same
market a week later correct I don't but
correct the thing is again you're with
your agent I'm with it my idea Brian's
where it's a major but the it's it's
like boxing these promoters game it and
it prevents greatness from happening it
really I don't get it because we have
the control if my if I call my agent now
hey man I want to do Bert Tom D'Elia
Brian Santino and D'Elia and he's like
do you only pry don't really want to
work in and I'm like [ __ ] you but I
promise everybody has different drawers
so then the money gets split up
differently right that's the problem
hold on this is my thing with all that
doing one of those like White Collar
Comedy Tour which you know which they
did back in the day with Ron wide and
[ __ ] all the boys you got to put
money the side and realize it's bigger
than that yeah you know like it's bigger
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue Oh what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]